as part of the beef and lamb new zealand
north canterbury farming for profit
program we've come to
marshdale with agricom to have a look at
the diverse pasture species
cropping program um and i've got
alastair moorhead here who's going to
have a bit of a chat to us about the
importance of species selection
in these diverse pasture species what to
sow
why to sew it and maybe what not to sow
ow oh thanks sarah so we've just
finished our field day here and uh
i'm approaching mid-april and we're in a
complex diverse pasture that we created
as part of a diverse pasture project
that involves
five different farmlets all
with elements of diversity uh including
a 50 year old
pasture that has been untouched and then
has naturalized over time
so i've got a piece of paper all names
on it because actually we put in about
28 species
and for me uh it's probably easier to go
through the list and
and look at what's around us a little
bit too but to
understand why we chose to do what and
what elements we came to play
here and then at the end acknowledge
things that are
definitely wouldn't do again both from
the financial input to putting them in
but also the environmental damage that
they may have occurred
with time so this pasture's been sown
with the equivalent of 18 kilograms of
rye grass
but with about eight or so grass species
sown at very low rates
and what i mean by 18 kgs of rye grass
i'm using that too
for you to visualize the quantity of all
the grasses if they add it up based on
seed size
how much equivalent rye grass we might
have put in
so as an example we've got only four
kilograms of perennial rye grass in here
a diploid perennial uh we've put four
kgs of a tetraploid hybrid in here which
again
because hi our tetraploid seed is bigger
four kilograms that's half the rate that
the deployed was
that's not an annual it's a hybrid it
will last over time
but it adds extra speed to the start of
this
but at a very low sowing rate uh we have
four k's of tall fescue in here
and again our seed size very similar to
perennial ryegrass
we have three k's of meadow fescue
4k is a batten prairie grass and that is
a shortest term species with a very big
seed
but it's also a natural reseeder as well
and it's quite common in fact you can
see a little bit here where it's already
thrown a seed
in its first season and and that will
start a regeneration phase as well
we have a little bit of garlic grazing
brome in here as well
and timothy so these are the species
that make up the grass base
this pasture was designed to be a
genuine perennial pasture
but with uh a cover crop of species that
might have
other attributes however that's only the
first part the second part definitely is
the legumes that support this pasture
so we're looking at red clover i see
that as a
powerhouse of this sort of opportunity
and system and already it's showing up
as impressive
the other legume that is showing up from
day one
to be extremely impressive as a lusun
and luciana's content here is
outstanding so
we've got four k's of red clover uh we
have
three k's of lucerne and i believe due
to the
slow establishment of the div of the low
sowing rates of the
grass species every kg of that lucian
seed
has germinated and is contributing
really strongly
inside the first season we've got three
white clovers
a large leaf and a medium large leaf and
a small leaf type
and uh we have a crimson clover a
balancer clover
and these are annual clovers both of
which that have
reseeded inside the stand because of
this
lacks start both of them are creating
longevity through reseeding and
contributing to
mass in the spring and the nitrogen
cycling coming from the legumes
we've put in some lotus and today we've
had an exercise about finding the plants
and the lotus is extremely hard to find
to start with
and i would emphasize on the scale of
this mixture the lotus is very expensive
so you need to have quite a lot of faith
that it works for you before you
probably would want to invest in that
uh what am i looking at strawberry
clover another very resilient uh white
clover like legume
designed for wet hard soils that get
very dry in summer
so we suffer from the dry in summer
we're looking for perenniality over the
years
and strawberry clover is a really
interesting
addition to that legume content ah
the herbs are covered off by chicory and
plantain
and would be fair to say from the
establishment phase the chicory is quite
outstanding
it has a lot of micronutrients that we
know it cycles particularly copper
and the plantain obviously copper and
selenium and cobalt in the right soil so
they
they have traits of both forage quality
but also animal
characteristics we had cover crop plants
for forage such as the milton
oats and the uh the rape and
radish which were used to bulk up the
start
and both those plants all those plants
have played their plant well
the oats to be fair are a fibre source
only and we aim to sow them at quite a
low rate
so they didn't overwhelm the rest of
this really valuable pasture mix
with too much fibre on top of the ground
when they're being grazed
and then after that we've got species
like sunflowers buckwheat lupins facilia
mustard linseed vetch now the key to
many of those vets is a really useful
species as a legume contributor here
both for reseeding and
and for contribution through the grazing
phase
uh the regrets really sit with the
mustard
and to be fair the radish they don't fit
the grazing rotation well
and we did not start the grazing of this
mix until 120 days
and didn't finish the first round for
180 days
and that time that mustard floured and
set seed and that seed has now
contaminated the soil for a very long
time and stop the future uses we could
have of this land
and put a few of our neighbours at risk
with birds moving seed into the rest of
the landscape
the radish is the same problem we still
have flowering radish plants here right
now
the seed will have been moved around
possibly mostly the paddock but also
possibly around
and that creates a pollen bear pollen
risk
to any other neighbor who may be trying
to do radish seed production
so there is a a social awareness that
needs to be had when placing these
plants in these really diverse
and really complex mixes um really
looking at this
uh there's some very powerful plants in
here
we've created a nice fibre mass that is
going to continue to break down over
this winter
they're going to go through winter and
this coming spring go to seed
that's going to give us the opportunity
to elevate our covers pre-grazing
and we're aiming for high covers and
high residuals in this particular
treatment
the other treatments are more intense
using similar species
not quite as great a diversity but in a
much more intense grazing cycle
and we're going to be paying attention
to what's going on underground as well
as above ground
and we'll leave you with that great
thanks al that's really really good this
is the beginning
of agricom's venture into some diverse
pasture species trial so it's going to
be awesome to come back and
see what they like in a few more years
time thank you very much all